it's very difficult to make that leap
however in our book God's brain Maguire
and I actually have a chapter on
chimpanzee religion religion in the
sense that there are periods during the
day that normal day of group of chimps
when they seem to engage in what we
would could call a religious type
service that is after they've had
breakfast there they closed their nests
and so on and and there they feel safe
they'll usually sit in some place which
is like a clearing and they're protected
by trees you might well say that it's
almost Cathedral like depending on where
they are and they exist with very
reduced attention the dominant males
don't bother the youngsters as much the
females interact with each other and the
youngsters and there's a lot of grooming
that goes on people not people chimps
grooming each other and that lasts for a
while and then they go back to their
regular business and so you could see
that there is in our repertoire a
predisposition to some kind of let's
take time off behavior and just be
friendly to each other
we've seen what happens when communities
become convinced that they're entirely
on their own
I guess the Nazis were a very good case
they really didn't believe in God even
though Germany had been a Catholic
community and Protestant and some of the
great religious thinkers came out of
Germany like Luther and so on it would
be very hard to answer your question
because so many of the world's most
terrible events have been because people
believed in God and it therefore would
be irresponsible to say that we should
have no religion because people would
act more nicely I'm not sure that's true
and we have only to look for example of
the the history of modern communism
which was really quite nasty
and that wasn't associated with God at
all and yet people in in what was the
former Soviet Union were very unclear
about where they stood so for example
it's highly symbolic that in Red Square
the center of Moscow the ceremonial
heart of the Russian Empire the the
Cathedral there st. Basil's had a
crucifix at the top of it staple now
after the Revolution what do you do
about that crucifix it took them 20
years to decide that things were okay
now and they replaced it with a red star
the Russians were just a little
concerned about this atheism business
and as we've seen now that Russia has
changed people are going back to the
churches there's much more attention to
religion so again it's not a proof it
does suggest however that if you have a
completely secular theory as the
Communists did it can produce menacing
and awful behavior and did